[TITLE MUSIC PLAYING]
LUCIEN AVRAMOV: In my
own words, modernization
is about basically
get on-premise, get
legacy virtualized
environments, and getting them
to you in a way where
you can actually run them
as containers, where
you can operate them
with less overhead for basically
programability upgrades,
patching, and how to run
in a cloud environment
in a more automatic way,
where you can start,
once you are there,
leveraging cloud products
and cloud tools that we offer.
So this is kind of our
view of modernization.
So I would say if you take a
virtual machine as a starting
point and we get to an
endpoint which would be running
on a container and having
CI/CD pipeline instrumentation,
having monitoring,
troubleshooting tools,
real-time, that will show you
what your application is doing
with the rest of the world--
how many customers
are touching it,
how many connections per second,
who this application is talking
with, which other application
it interfaces with, what's
the latency, and so forth.
That's one part.
And then the other
part is, well, how
do I upgrade my application?
How do I patch it?
How do I move it?
How do I make sure it scales?
And so once you are
in this environment,
you are modernized.
And so this is what
modernization means to me.
And now what I'd like
to cover is basically
to see why we're doing
it, why we're modernizing.
So enterprise IT is complex.
Why is it complex?
Because you're in
an environment where
you have multiple different
systems in your infrastructure.
You may have virtualized
environments.
You may have bare-metal.
You may have legacy middleware.
And basically you'll
end up in an environment
where you have a bunch
of things to make work.
And you need to make them evolve
because your task to evolve
this system.
So your initial starting
point is complicated.
And that's what you have.
And that's your environment.
And basically for your
company and your environment
to be responsive
and competitive,
it has to quickly evolve.
If you have a new
application coming up,
a new service that you want
to offer to your customers,
you have to quickly do it.
And so on the one
hand, you're facing
the environment that exists.
On the other hand,
there is a need
of more and more agility
into your environment,
faster and faster deployment
times for applications
and so forth.
And so we started
being in a place where
we needed to do trade-offs.
And the trade-offs are in three
different types, basically.
One is about
security and agility.
So you want to be agile,
but at the same time
you want your application
to be secure enough.
And so you start to think
how to get more agile.
But at the same time,
your security teams
would not want this to be
more impactful with the data.
So you have to think about
these two, how they coexist.
That's number one.
Number two is
reliability and cost.
So you want to basically have
an infrastructure where cost
is less and less and so forth.
but at the same time,
you want it reliable.
You don't want to have failures.
You don't want to have outages.
You want uptime in SLOs.
You want to make sure that
if you have customers using
your environment that are in
Asia, in Europe, in the US,
that based on who they
are and where they are,
they have a latency and
an application response
time that suits what you
want to provide to them.
And same for internal
applications.
So if you are hosting your
internal applications somewhere
on the cloud, you want to
make sure that A, it works,
and, two, that it
works well enough
with the proper performance.
And then number three is
portability and consistency.
So how can I move my application
to a different environment?
How can I go from my
on-premise to the cloud?
How can I go back from the
cloud to an on-premise?
How can I have
multiple clouds coexist
and at the same time be agile?
If a new service
appears somewhere
and I want my application
to benefit from it,
I'd like to move it there.
And so that's the
thinking of the trade-offs
that we need to do in order
to basically modernize
an environment.
And basically what
we need to embrace
is how do we do new things?
How do we transform this
IT environment versus doing
the same thing somewhere else?
So what a CIO of a
media company found
is that 90% of
legacy apps would not
be optimized by
moving to the cloud.
By just moving an
application, it
doesn't mean that you start
benefiting from all what
the cloud has to offer you.
And if you don't
modernize, what happens?
Well, you have
underutilized resources.
You have turnover.
Some people may go somewhere
else, losing interest
and so forth.
Downtime-- you have
downtime as well
because you're not more modern.
You don't have a
24/7 reliability.
You have to have
maintenance windows.
You have to take
downtime to upgrade.
And so that's another
part of not modernizing.
And third, while
you may be locked
in with specific vendors
and not have the agility
to move when you want to move--
and there's more and more
this need to adapt yourself
to the environment
because there's so many
new ways to do business and
to do technical application
deployments and so many new
softwares and ways of doing
the same thing somewhere
else and in another ways
that you want to be more--
you want to give yourself
the chances to succeed.
And this is why we're so much
thinking about modernization
and why we're spending time on
this product for modernizing.
And so basically the fact
that you will modernize,
it's not that it's basically
an end of something
and you have to rebuild and
figure out how to do it.
It's basically a way
to find a different way
to build your environment in
a modernized infrastructure.
And so the technologies
for modernization,
here I put the five
key ones that I see.
Microservices-- what
does microservices mean?
Microservices means
the flexibility
to move at the speed that
your developers move.
Containers-- containers means
repetitive, repeatability and
scalability.
You can run something of--
you can have an
application that's portable
and that can be
repeated and moved
to various places
in a faster way.
Orchestration-- what
does orchestration mean?
It means that we have systems
that will automate and move
these applications
where it makes
sense when it makes sense.
CI/CD, what is that?
That means that you will
be shipping code hourly,
and you will be agile.
You won't be on the
quarterly basis--
for example, the
development release.
You will just push the
code when it's available
and when it's tested.
And these are the services
and API management.
So automate your management
with basically having an API
framework where you will
touch other applications
and you will have
a tight integration
between different parts
of your lifecycle,
different applications
in your lifecycle.
So these are the
technologies that
are part of this
modernization journey.
It is a big deal when we look at
customer surveys and basically
market surveys.
Migration and modernization
are a big deal
what you see here is
migrating existing
applications to the cloud,
most people believe in that.
Evolving the application is
also important and top of mind.
So these are really
key aspects in terms
of modernizing
infrastructure, and that's
what we get from markets.
Now, the problem with that is
that it's actually complicated.
It's hard.
It's a hard thing to do.
Everyone wants to modernize,
but how do we do it?
And when we look at some more
and more data, more statistics,
over 90% of enterprises
migration projects
face delays over budget.
Why is it so hard?
Number one, the scale.
So you have thousands of
workloads, for example,
in a data center, and you need
to move that to the cloud.
How do you do it?
So you will start evaluating
solutions, doing a scale
of one, 10, 20 workloads.
How do you do this at scale?
How do you go thousands of VMs?
How do you move a physical
data center to the cloud?
It's a hard thing to do.
It involves planning,
understanding
the framework, the architecture,
the networking, the security
bits, and then being able
to do that on the cloud.
So it's actually an extension
of your environment.
Multi-source-- well, there are
certain things that you cannot
move to the cloud.
For legal reasons, for
practical reasons--
there is a bunch of
different reasons
where you will
need to run, still,
certain applications
on your data center,
at physical locations.
And they should co-exist
with the ones that you move.
And so therefore, when you
move certain things away,
run them on the cloud.
And they have to talk
to your on-premise.
You need to make sure that,
where they are, again, latency
is good enough, response time,
SLAs, and all these things.
So that's multi-source.
Three, well, the
applications are
complex multi-tier applications.
If we look at databases, if we
look at services that you run,
typically they're
developed by someone,
and then oftentimes you know
that the application is running
and it's a complex
application solving
one of the things in your
environment, in your company,
but you don't know
how to upgrade it,
you don't know what it's doing.
And you still would
like to migrate it.
So you would like to have
tools that figure out
what the application
is, and then
enable you to take that to the
cloud in a way that makes sense
and to still have it functional.
So we also have that
part of capability
with what we were looking
at, with Anthos Migrate.
And the last part is the risk.
So we oftentimes talk--
when we talk migration, we talk
about moving you to the cloud
and migrating you.
But one aspect that's
not often talked about
is, well, what do you
do if it doesn't work?
You want to make sure you can
actually go back on-premise.
And so the software for
migration that you look at,
you want to have a seamless
way of actually moving
to the cloud, but
also back on-premise.
And so you want an environment
that gives you that flexibility
and gives you the same time
frame or the same performance,
whether you go to the cloud
or whether you come back
on-premise at any given time.
So this is our solution when
we look at modernization
and how we do it.
So what I will tell you
now is about our product,
Anthos Migrate that gives
you this modernization
aspect for your workloads.
And what we modernized is
that we take workloads running
on bare-metal on
virtual machines,
whether it's on your
on-premise or whether it's
on a different cloud.
And how do we take
those workloads?
Windows or Linux.
And we move them over to GCP.
And when it's Linux,
today, we actually
move them into containers.
And so it's a one-step
process to get you directly
to the container journey,
and to get you to run on GKE.
And that's really the value
here, the leap of technology
we're taking into
modernizing your VM
running somewhere,
and then ending up
as this VM runs in
a container on GKE.
And then you can leverage all
the ecosystem of the things
that we talk about around GKE.
So this is our vision.
It's about migrating
and modernizing the VMs.
And the way we will take
you there is-- basically
it can be a one-step process or
it can be a multi-step process,
depending on how ready you
are and where in your journey
you are.
And what you see
here on this graph,
we start to read this graph
by the bottom left side, which
is your starting point.
You're either on-premise
or another cloud,
and you have a workload.
Then you can actually go
directly and end your journey
as running, on the top left
side, as a container on GKE.
You can do that directly
with Anthos Migrate,
or we can do it also in a
two-step process with Anthos
Migrate.
So we can take you first to
run on, for example, GCP.
So we can get your VM to
run as a VM on Google Cloud,
and then modernize it, or we
can modernize it directly.
So depending on where
you are in your journey,
you don't have to wait for this.
You can start, and
we can meet you
in your journey of
modernization, where you are.
Here is our approach.
And our approach is
this two possible phase.
This is the journey
of a migration.
And I'm trying to show
you here the lifecycle.
So we start with a pre-sale,
first, environment,
where when we have
conversations about migration,
we talk about discovery.
And what discovery
is is to figure out
what your environment is,
what really is happening
in your IT environment, what
applications are running, what
are the dependencies,
where are they located,
what is their network, what
are the security policies,
and so forth.
Then comes the
migration planning,
which is still a more of a paper
phase or a discovery phase,
which we start thinking
about what are we going
to migrate, when, and how.
And then we go into our,
basically, next step,
which is our migration practice.
And what you see here
is two different trains
that we can take.
The top one that we run on GCE--
so the top one is we take
a VM running on-premise,
and then we go and run
that as a migration,
and we end up on GCE.
So that's our
lift-and-shift technology.
And at the bottom
one, you see our type
of doing that with GKE.
So similar processes, but
it's just that we can adapt
the journey to where you are.
And this is why we--
this is what we offer
you with our software,
with Anthos Migrate.
So I want to go through
the benefits of two things.
I want to go over the
VM-to-VM migration,
and then I'll tell you about
our VM-to-GKE migration, so
the two different
aspects of our product.
What you see with our
VM-to-VM migration
is that we actually
want to move you.
It's our lift and shift.
We want to move
you to Google Cloud
with a fast-paced technology.
The way we achieve
that is we actually
have a couple of key benefits.
One is we have what we
call real-time streaming.
With real-time
streaming, what we
do is when start your
migration journey,
see it as, when you're
running a VM on-premise,
we start a VM on
Google Cloud, on GCP.
So in about five to
10 minutes, depending
if it's Windows or Linux,
we fire up the VM in GCP.
The disk, the data, the
storage of your initial VM
is basically streamed to your
destination VM on the cloud,
and then we cache it
and we transfer the data
in the background.
So what this means
for you is that you
actually, within minutes, know
if your migrated workload is
actually operational.
And you don't have to wait
for the whole migration
to finish to then
test it and see
if it's actually functioning.
So within minutes, you
can test the migration,
and we can migrate
storage in the background.
This allows us to
accelerate the migration,
and really to make it
meaningful to you in a sense
that you actually can understand
if your destination result will
actually work with
what you want it to be.
We don't need to install
agents on your VM.
It's an agentless design.
We can test before migration,
and we can roll back.
So with these benefits what
you see on the chart is
you can actually,
over time, migrate
a lot more at-scale VMs.
And this is real customer data.
You can migrate, at scale,
thousands and thousands of VMs
with our automated process.
And scale of operations--
another thing to show
you here is, the VMs,
so say we take a two-week
migration journey,
which is fairly typical
for production migrations--
first week is discovery, second
week is the implementation--
you can actually see
that, in our second week,
the migration completes very--
the VM starts
running right away,
and then the data being
transferred in the background,
we're actually getting you
up and running very quickly
in that second phase when
it's the real migration.
And that's with the
technology that we
have behind Anthos Migrate.
Now let's talk about
the second point.
So I told you about
VM-to-VM migration.
Now it's about VM to containers.
So you're developing
applications,
and your new applications
are, say, running on GKE
or running as containers.
But now you also have
legacy workloads.
And for those, you don't
want to rewrite them.
But if you can move them
to the cloud and on GKE,
then you can instrument
them and interface them
with the modern microservices
that you're building
and take advantage of
the same benefits of GKE
where we manage
the kernel for you.
You have access to
our CI/CD pipeline
where you can use other services
such as Istio and services mesh
and interact with your
microservice applications.
So we take those legacy apps
where rewrite is not an option,
and we have it to run for
you in a container on GCP.
Why wouldn't you just
do a lift and shift?
Well, if you were just
doing lift and shift,
and just moving it
as a VM, you would
get some benefits,
but not as much
as if you run as a
container, especially because
of the modernization reasons
that we were talking about.
And then, finally, we
don't see the migration
as a binary problem.
We have customers that
understand that containers,
GKE, and so forth
is interesting,
although they don't see all
the benefits right away.
We can meet you where you are
in your migration journey,
and we can take you through
that step forward to GKE.
So it's a further toolbox
that you have for your app.
And another point here is,
well, why do we do this?
A big reason why this comes
back is customers love GKE.
GKE is, today, a leading
container managed service
that a lot of our
customers just want
to be on because of all
the other benefits we have
once you are on GKE.
And legacy apps, once
they're there, again,
they're onboarded, you start
to see the benefit of it.
So now think about if you
had to move two containers,
your own apps, yourself, and
rewrite them or rebuild them,
and you have to do that
at scale, it's probably
not something that's going
to be either happening
or that's going to be really
appealing for you to do,
so they may end up staying.
So what we do with our
capability of running
these legacy workloads--
middleware, databases
and so forth--
we enable you to meet us in
the cloud journey very quickly.
And we run these containers,
same as our VM-to-VM migration,
about five minutes or so, you're
up and running with the data.
What you saw today
at our keynote
was a migration of
an online boutique
app that would start
to run on-premise,
and then goes to the cloud.
It takes about a minute or so
to move that with our streaming
technology.
So I have another example
which is fairly similar.
This is about an SAP
database, for example,
where we do a migration.
And what you see with
that migration is
the time it takes to run
in the cloud and the time
it takes to complete.
So this was for 36 servers
with 3.25 terabytes of data.
The full migration was done
in 36 hours, so completely
complete, end to end.
So that's the landscape.
That's what it takes
when doing the live data
migration, 36 hours.
If you look at using
Anthos Migrate,
you're up and running in the
cloud already in three hours.
And that's a real production
SAP large database.
A little bit about our process--
this is my last slide.
This is just so you
understand what happens.
The modernization starts
from Kubernetes itself.
From GKE, we actually decide
to start the migration
with the YAML file.
Then our initial
starting point is
a data center where you have
virtual machines running on.
There's the hypervisor
stacks that are storage.
This is the middle picture here.
So GKE start the modernization
process with a YAML.
And basically, our
Anthos Migrate software
moves those two VMs into
two new containers on GKE,
as you can see on your
right-hand side here.
And when they're on
GKE, you basically
can leverage all the
ecosystem around that.
So that's the whole idea.
The whole idea here is we
start migrating from Kubernetes
itself, and then we
end up with these VMs
running in specific clusters
as StatefulSets and up
and running on Kubernetes.
So once you're there,
everything that's automation--
pipeline, modern tools,
orchestration, API management,
services about security,
mesh, Istios, and so forth--
are things you can
leverage right away.
Last slide-- what
can we migrate?
So here is the example
of our workloads.
It's mainly going to be
Tomcat, web server, web apps,
multi-tier apps.
It's going to be Websphere,
Weblogic, there's
going to be databases.
And basically we support the
operating systems that you see,
which are Linux--
Red Hat and CentOS,
SUSE, and Ubuntu.
So that's currently what we
support in our environments.
We are looking to do
Windows, and we'll
talk about that later on.
But that's what we support
currently with our product.
So key benefits at a glance--
once you are on Kubernetes,
here are the things
that you can benefit from.
First one is, you can run
your Stateful app in GKE.
Two, you have access to
the security aspects of GKE
that we offer.
Three, you're moving fast in
a standard containerized way.
And then we offer you
an easier to rebuild app
to run in a modern environment,
manageability, OS patching,
and automated pipeline.
So this is more of a
summary of key benefits
just to get everyone on board
with what we're bringing on
with Kubernetes.
So with that, we have another
about 20 minutes or so.
What I'd like to do
next is to actually talk
to you about our
real-world case studies.
And in a second, I
will call up our--
actually I call up our
customers to come up onstage.
What I wanted you to see is some
examples of our applications
that we can migrate
and modernize.
CRM application, for example,
Weblogic, JBOSS, SAP--
all these are examples of things
that we can migrate to GKE.
So with that, I would like
to call our three customers
on stage.
We have Michael, Walker,
and Luke that will join us
and so we can have
a little panel
for the remaining of the time.
While they get set up, what
I'd like to tell everyone--
we also have a
DORIE that's open.
So if you have questions
now that you'd like to ask,
we can then follow up as
questionnaire after that.
So don't hesitate
to use the DORIE.
And now we'll go ahead
and talk about the panel.
So first, thank
you for joining me.
Thank you, Michael,
Walker, and Luke.
First thing I'd like to
do is to ask you about--
tell me about your companies.
So tell me about
what you're doing
and how that pertains to cloud.
So Michael, if you'd
like to start, maybe,
and tell us about
Atos and who you
are and introduce your company.
MICHAEL KOLLAR: Sure.
So my name's Michael Kollar.
I run cloud
engineering for Atos.
We're a global-managed
service provider.
And we help our customers,
one, run existing workloads
and systems, but also, we
help migrate them to cloud.
And a lot of that is through
whether it be fully transformed
in the cloud, running full
microservices and containers,
or some of it is lift and shift.
And we do it on a
variety of platforms,
including the legacy.
So for us, a lot
of legacy support,
where we integrate cloud-modern
technologies with legacy
through things like Cloud
Service Broker, [? Istio. ?]
And some of the
transformation capabilities
we get from Velostrata.
LUCIEN AVRAMOV:
Thank you, Michael.
Walker, how about you?
WALKER MILLER: Yeah.
I'm Walker Miller.
I'm from Cardinal Health.
We are a global health
care, pharmaceutical,
and medical supplies
manufacturer and distributor.
We have been in the process
for the last couple of years
of doing a massive migration
from on-premise to cloud,
using--
well, Velostrata, at the
time, is what it was.
We are just about finished.
We'll be done in July with most
of our production instances.
And we've been experimenting
a bit with this new product,
as well.
LUCIEN AVRAMOV: Thank you.
Luke?
LUKE WEBB: I'm Luke Webb.
I'm on the Cloud Enablement
Team with Tyson Foods.
So we're a food company.
We did about $40 billion
in sales last year
across our four main BUs,
which are beef, poultry, pork,
and prepared foods.
So we operate across multiple
states and multiple countries.
And our IT workforce is also
spread across those locations.
We started a cloud migration
and a digital transformation
about 18 months ago.
And so we've been doing
a lot of discovery,
a lot of testing,
a lot of deciding
on how we want to do things.
So we know how we
want to do things.
And we just want
to figure out how
to get there to that end state.
So we have a pretty aggressive
cloud migration strategy.
And Velostrata is going
to be part of that.
LUCIEN AVRAMOV: Let's talk
a little bit about scale.
And I think, Walker, you're
one of our lead examples.
Tell us about scale,
in terms of how large,
or where are you, in terms
of that journey of migrating?
You've experienced our
product with migrating
certain workloads and then
moving a higher amount.
How has that process
been for you?
And do you foresee a
similar type of activity
for potentially containers?
As you look at your
modernization journey,
are you also
thinking maybe scale?
How do you see that to fit
your model for your company?
WALKER MILLER: Yeah.
Well, I think when
we're done, we'll
have migrated around
4,000 servers.
We're probably about
75%, 80% done with that.
We just got production
[? to knock ?] off--
probably getting closer
to 85%, 90% here.
So yeah, we've been doing
it over a couple of years.
Spent a lot of time doing
discovery and analysis, which
allowed us to be successful.
As far as the container,
I'm not really sure
yet what that's
going to look like.
I think that's
kind of new to us.
We've been doing it
internally with a few apps,
just kind of building
cloud-native,
just to get an idea.
We'll be going live with our
first production Kubernetes
app in May.
So we're still kind
of early adopters
in there, as well, for us.
And I don't know
what the end game
is going to look like
for that quite yet.
But I have a feeling--
an inkling-- that
containers are going
to be a pretty integral part of
that for all of our technology
staff.
LUCIEN AVRAMOV: Mhm.
Thank you.
Michael, we talked about--
a little bit earlier,
you were telling me about
migrations, in general,
and containers.
Do you foresee this
technology, that it's something
that you'd like to
take for modernizing
a lot of your customer breadth
or activities with containers?
How do you see
our new technology
with containers to play a
role for Atos, compared to,
say, traditional lift
and shift or moving
to the cloud activities
for basically your company?
MICHAEL KOLLAR: Yeah.
So we've built a
platform in partnership
with Google that we call the
Orchestrated Hybrid Cloud.
It's based on Kubernetes.
And it's a
container-based platform
for microservice applications--
microservice-based
applications.
One of the things we need to
do is take legacy applications
at scale and move
them to containers
and essentially break
down the dependencies
that they had on
operating systems, VMWare,
and some of the other
proprietary technologies
that we had.
So in order to facilitate that,
we needed a technology that
allowed us to, one,
do that separation,
but then also create what I
would say are smaller, more
segmented apps--
microservices-- onto
a modern platform
that we could then integrate
and then orchestrate
whether they be
on-prem, because we
have a requirement--
some of our customers
still want
infrastructure on-prem.
Like it or not, they've got
regulatory requirements,
things of that nature.
But then also, provide the way
to scale it and integrate it
with public cloud offerings
that make more sense for them.
So for us, containerization
is critical to transform
customers.
And we have customers today
that are building cloud-native
applications that way, and also
want to take some of what they
would refer to as their
low-hanging fruit--
tier three and tier four apps--
that really don't make sense
to keep on-prem anymore--
that they could just
move to the cloud
and do that in a
container-based approach
and take full advantage of
what Google has to offer there.
LUCIEN AVRAMOV: Thank you.
Luke, how about you?
So for Tyson Foods, how do
you see that model to play?
What type of
applications, potentially,
do you see for migration,
in general, I would say,
to the cloud?
What are the top of minds?
And what are you
thinking, in terms
of containers and
migrations to that,
in terms of type of workloads
that you're looking at?
LUKE WEBB: Yeah.
So everything in our data center
is on the block for migration
to the cloud.
And containers are definitely
part of our strategy.
Anything cloud-native
that we're building,
we're definitely pushing
development teams to use
Kubernetes, microservices,
Cloud Functions--
those kind of technologies.
But as far as migrating, what we
have in our data centers today,
we're not sure would all those
things fit into Kubernetes.
So we have a lot
of ERP systems that
maybe don't fit that model.
But we do have some
web-hosted applications that
definitely would fit in there.
And we have a lot of
Windows VMs, which
aren't on the beta
release of this software
but are on the roadmap.
So we're interested to see
what comes in that space,
as far as Windows VM to
Kubernetes migration tools.
LUCIEN AVRAMOV: Windows, yeah.
OK.
Great.
In terms of, I would say,
challenges, what do you
gentlemen see as potentially
current challenges
for migration?
What is it for you that's the
biggest challenge, I would say,
or one of the biggest challenge
when you look at migrations?
What are the blockers for you
today for your environments?
MICHAEL KOLLAR: So I can give
you two that we struggle with.
So embedded security
inside of apps
is something that,
even when we do
the discoveries and things like
that, we don't typically find.
Someone did role-based access.
You go back in time, the
products lack integrity
and stuff like that, did
role provision dynamically
for the user.
So how that happens
in the public cloud
is going to be
very different when
we do that migration
because that service is
no longer there.
So we're going to have to
do something to recreate it.
The second area that we
get a little hung up on is
the ability to deal
with or roll back
because the batch processes
we have to support
are downstream dependencies.
Sometimes when we
migrate an application
or we containerize it, the
same way that that app got
triggered previously
in its previous state,
is no longer the
same way we would
want to do it in the future,
because the legacy systems
don't understand
event-based programming
and things of that nature
that we do for the new world.
So we have to look
at, how do we deal
with keeping some
of those events,
or externalizing
those events, to keep
some of the systems that
don't come over in sync?
So security and embedded
types of batch processes
and legacy-type
integration approaches
are some of the inhibitors
or blockers we see when
we're migrating the containers.
LUCIEN AVRAMOV:
Thank you, Michael.
WALKER MILLER: Yeah, I would say
with the migration as a whole,
our biggest problem was just
knowing what talks to what.
So discovery was our
biggest challenge.
It's just because of the nature
of on-prem and segregation
of duties.
You had application
teams that didn't really
fully understand how
their applications worked
with other things.
So going through and
digging through all the data
we had to in order to figure out
that was probably the biggest
challenge we had-- clearly,
the biggest challenge we had.
As far as moving
something to Kubernetes,
the technology doesn't
scare me at all.
The technology is pretty sound.
We've been playing with
traditional [? Webster ?]
application server
in Kubernetes.
And even just building it
natively, it works well.
That's not a real issue.
If you're running,
at least on Linux,
you're going to run in
a container pretty well.
One of the reasons we like
Kubernetes over other options
is that it allows you
to run in that way, too.
You don't necessarily have
to make it cloud-native.
Or you don't have to
be a microservice.
You can be a traditional VM.
So it works out.
I think the biggest challenge,
for us, is going to be vendors
and just dealing
with them and making
sure they're willing to support
us running into a container
environment.
I liken it of the move
from physical to VMs years
ago, which I had the
luxury of being around for.
And when you went to a
lot of vendors and said,
hey, we want to run this on
in a virtualized environment,
they just said, no, we're
not going to support it.
And eventually,
that turn happened.
And I feel like that turn
will happen here, as well.
LUKE WEBB: I would say,
probably resource constraints
have been our biggest
challenge so far.
Ever since we started
our cloud journey,
we've been on a big project.
We had acquired
another company that
had their entire IT
infrastructure, their own ERP
systems.
So we've been
combining those two.
We were founded in 1935.
So we're definitely a
born analog company.
And we have a lot
of old processes
that got pushed
into an ERP system.
Well, we modified
our ERP system.
It's a highly customized system.
So part of this journey is
just a digital transformation
to use SAS software,
like SAS software,
and not modify it
unless there's some sort
of distinguishing feature
of Tyson operations.
So really, a lot
of resources have
been tied up in that effort.
So resources, and
then skill set--
when the resources
are tied up elsewhere,
they can't develop
the cloud skills
that they need to get
onto this new platform
for our next generation
of applications.
So a tool like VM to GKE is
definitely very attractive.
If you can get a push-button
move into a new, more
modern environment,
then you don't
have to take all that
time from your developers
and your IT team to get
them onto that new platform.
LUCIEN AVRAMOV: So
security is one aspect.
Another aspect is
basically talking about--
you mentioned about
support for application
from vendors when
you go to the cloud
and how are you supported.
And another one is obviously
what you mentioned, as well,
with the various things
that you have to manage,
and then on-boarding
them to the cloud.
What we seem to see
is a few things.
So one is, I think that
what you brought up,
Walker, about the
support for certain
supports on containers--
I think this is more
of a time constraint
that's going to ease up
because I think it's something
that we see, that everyone
wants to move to containers.
So I think we start to
see various companies more
open on the support model.
So I think that's more on
the, I would say, support.
And it's very important
for production.
But I think we'll get there.
In terms of security and what
we do once you're containers,
I think that what
we're now working
on Istio with the
service mesh is
going to be really
compelling, in terms
of adding more
security, and then
with [INAUDIBLE]
and identity, to be
able to basically have a user.
So if you are on the
Active Directory Windows
type of environment,
now you can actually--
if you take our Anthos
migrate software now,
we can actually
directly map to users
that are in ADs to be moved to
containers to GKE with the IM
settings of GCP.
So I think the security
aspect is definitely key,
because we want to make
sure we conserve that.
But that's a really
interesting problem
that we're looking to solve.
And then you mentioned, Luke, I
think also Windows and Windows
containers.
So Windows is a big
thing, especially
for legacy applications.
This comes oftentimes--
well, I'd love to go to GKE,
but I have Windows, so
what do I do with Windows?
We're actually working
on the Windows part.
This is something you
will see later on.
It's on our roadmap.
We started now with
Windows and containers.
So we're starting to have
alpha and early access
type of things.
So I think the Windows part is
something that we're definitely
aware on and working on.
But in terms of getting
into containers,
our software really has
the value of taking your VM
and booting it up as
a StatefulSet on GKE.
So we're not yet at a stage
where we break an application
into microservices.
But the first step
of what we're doing
is, we take your legacy VM,
and then we get that to boot up
and running a container.
And then it can start
interface with other things.
And at the same time,
once it's on containers,
you actually get more scale.
So you could actually
get a lot more
workloads to run on a GKE
cluster versus, say, a VM
cluster.
So these were kind of
things where we are.
What I wanted to ask
you guys is, maybe,
what would be a one
top-of-mind thing
that you would like
to see in the product?
Or what are the things
that you're thinking of--
once you're in
containers, what would you
like to see that may
be missing or that
is top-of-mind for
you as a next step
to maybe get you more towards
a container environment?
Anyone?
LUKE WEBB: Well, I think you
just touched on it for us.
So getting a VM or a legacy app
up into containers is great.
But it doesn't break it down
into a microservices-type
architecture for you.
So just like Walker
mentioned, that the discovery
is the hardest part.
So anything that a tool
could do to help you
discover how an application
talks to other applications
and what databases
it is required of--
those kind of things
would really be helpful.
WALKER MILLER: The full
integration with Istio
is going to be nice.
Again, and the
idea of discovery--
if we had had a service,
much like Istio, in place--
or any service mesh in
place, for that matter--
that would have made
that a lot easier,
because we would have been
able to see those interactions
a lot better than we do now.
So service mesh is kind of
high on our list for just
kind of all of our workloads.
MICHAEL KOLLAR: And I
would like to also see,
given that we spend a lot of
times integrating with legacy
systems with our
customers, understanding
how we can provide the mapping
back to the legacy within it
as part of the discovery
process to keep
those two worlds in sync as
we progress them forward.
LUCIEN AVRAMOV: So yeah, moving
basically integration with CSM,
how to move these apps, and
how do we do microservices--
so the microservices part is
something that we're thinking
to do--
it's in our ideas.
And that's something
hard to do is now,
once you are on a container and
you run as a StatefulSet, well,
you'd like that to
become microservices.
So how do we break that
monolith application
that's stateful to get you
to a stateless, server-less,
completely autonomous
type of application?
So that's also something that
is part of what we're thinking
about, in terms of solving.
But now we're looking at
basically taking your own GKE
and moving forward with that.
So I'm personally very
excited to collaborate
with you guys on
this and for you
to be our partners
on the journey,
as we started all this
testing and product.
So we'll continue, basically,
that and iterate on it.
That makes sense.
It's taking VMs, getting
people in containers,
scaling it out at big scale--
thousands and thousands
of workloads--
and then giving you the
flexibility of the cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]